Nos han dado información sobre estos tres
triángulos que tenemos aquí, y nos dicen:
"Usa uno de los triángulos", tenemos que usar uno
de estos tres triángulos, "para estimar la razón
de la longitud del segmento PN dividido entre la
longitud del segmento MN", de modo que nos piden
calcular la razón de PN / MN. Pausa el video y
trata de resolverlo. Muy bien, ahora trabajemos
juntos. Ahora, dado que nos piden evaluar o
calcular esta razón aproximadamente, probablemente
estamos tratando con semejanza, así que estamos
buscando uno de estos triángulos que sea semejante
al triángulo que tenemos aquí. Si tenemos dos
ángulos en común estamos tratando con triángulos
semejantes, porque si tenemos dos ángulos en común
eso significa que definitivamente el tercer ángulo
también es igual, ya que el tercer ángulo está
completamente determinado por el valor de los
otros dos ángulos. De modo que aquí tenemos un
ángulo de 35° y aquí tenemos un ángulo de 90°,
y de todas estas opciones este no tiene
un ángulo de 35°, tiene uno de 90;
este no tiene un ángulo de 35°, tiene uno de 90;
pero el triángulo número 2 tiene un ángulo de 35°,
tiene un ángulo de 90° y tiene un ángulo de
55°. Y si ya hiciste los cálculos, sabiendo
que 35 + 90 más este tienen que sumar 180°,
verás que este también tiene una medida de 55°,
y dado que los ángulos del triángulo PNM miden lo
mismo que los del triángulo número 2 que tenemos
aquí, sabemos que estos dos son triángulos
semejantes, así que las razones entre los
lados correspondientes van a ser iguales para los
dos. Podríamos calcular la razón entre los dos
triángulos o podríamos calcular la razón dentro de
un solo triángulo, y si vemos PN / MN -trataré de
usar un código de colores-: PN está justo aquí,
y corresponde al lado opuesto del ángulo de 35°,
este lado correspondería a este lado, justo
a este lado del triángulo 2; luego MN,
este que estoy coloreando de azul, es opuesto
al ángulo de 55°, y el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 55° sería justo este. Ahora, dado que estos
triángulos son semejantes, la razón que existe
entre la longitud del lado rojo y la longitud del
lado azul va a ser igual en cualquier triángulo.
Déjenme escribirlo de esta manera: la longitud del
segmento PN sobre la longitud del segmento MN va
a ser equivalente a 5.7 / 8.2, porque esta razón
va a ser igual para los lados correspondientes,
independientemente del triángulo que mires,
de modo que tomas el lado opuesto a 35°,
que es 5.7 / 8.2. Ahora, para ser muy clara,
esto no significa que la longitud de este lado
sea 5.7 o que la longitud de este lado sea 8.2,
sólo podríamos llegar a esa conclusión si fueran
triángulos congruentes, pero con triángulos
semejantes sabemos que la razón del lado rojo
al lado azul en cada uno de estos triángulos
es igual, esta es la razón. Veamos: 5.7 / 8.2,
¿cuál de estas opciones se acerca a esa razón?
Bueno, podríamos decir que esto es más o menos,
si lo estoy aproximando, veamos, va a ser
mayor que 0.57 porque 8.2 es menor que 10,
así que vamos a descartar esta opción, y 5.7 es
menor que 8.2 así que no puede ser mayor que 1,
de modo que tenemos que elegir entre estas dos
opciones. Bueno, lo más simple que puedo hacer es
dividirlo a mano, así que 8.2 cabe en 5.7 el mismo
número de veces que 82 en 57, agregaré algunos
decimales por aquí. No cabe en 57, ¿pero cuántas
veces cabe 82 en 570? Creo que aproximadamente
6 veces, tal vez 7 veces, entonces 7 x 2 = 14 y
luego 7 x 8 es 56 más 1 esto es 57. En realidad es
menor que 0.7. Esto fue un poco alto. Si me estoy
aproximando será 0.6 y algo. Me gusta la opción B.